howard el principal general de sudán es
ahora el presidente del consejo soberano
de transición abdel fattah al burham
quien protagonizó el golpe militar del
pasado 25 de octubre ha conformado un
gabinete de gobierno compuesto por 15
miembros 9 repite en el cargo mientras
que 6 de ellos son nuevos representantes
civiles de diferentes regiones del país
así lo anunció la televisión estatal
sudanesa para el general abdelfatah
burhan jefe del consejo soberano de
transición emitió el decreto
presidencial número 21 por el que se
constituye el consejo soberano de
transición con el anuncio el consejo
desplegó un gran dispositivo de fuerzas
de seguridad en las principales
carreteras de la capital jartúm como
prevención a posibles manifestaciones
contra el actual régimen que cuenta con
escasa popularidad interna y externa
obviamente estamos analizando estos
acontecimientos yo diría que son muy
preocupantes queremos que se retomen la
transición lo antes posible
de translation es posble queremos ver la
liberación del arresto domiciliario del
primer ministro hanbok así como todos
los demás políticos y líderes que han
sido detenidos o sessions
reuters de repente el 25 de octubre al
burham declaró el estado de emergencia y
disolvió el gabinete de transición
democrática en el país africano además
detuvo al primer ministro a delahunt doc
en arresto domiciliario el levantamiento
militar puso fin a un acuerdo de reparto
de poder entre militares y civiles
establecido tras el derrocamiento del ex
presidente omar al-bashir en 2019 que
debía conducir a las elecciones a
finales de 2023